el ministro de las fuerzas militares
advirtió hoy que la ventana para la
evacuación humanitaria se está empezando
a cerrar el reino unido tiene
organizados 11 vuelos para las próximas
24 horas pero no sabemos a qué punto
esta alerta de un posible atentado
terrorista puede afectar esos planes de
evacuar más personas de afganistán no
solamente ciudadanos británicos que se
encuentran en ese terreno sino también a
todas las personas nacionales de
afganistán que sirvieron como
intérpretes en estos 20 años de guerra
en ese país de ocupación el primer
ministro boris johnson ha hablado hace
pocos minutos a los medios británicos y
ha dicho que 15 mil personas han sido
evacuados por las tropas británicas y ha
prometido además que todas las personas
que son elegibles para salir de ese país
lo harán en las próximas horas pero
recordemos el reloj que va corriendo
para que llegue a esa fecha en cinco
días del 31 de agosto cuando se cumple
la fecha límite dada por para la
retirada de las tropas de ese país y
entonces las tropas occidentales pero
desafortunadamente ya el gobierno
británico ha advertido que todas las
personas no podrán salir de afganistán
especialmente quienes no están